900 shooting days Antarctica you heard
that and you thought how they get the
short straw fortunately I stand on the
shoulders of 23 amazing cinematographers
and from the NSA we were able to get 23
what they call beds which is places to
stay in Antarctica so I was in the wilds
of Burbank during the the shooting wait
you never had to put on the gear and go
down I never had to go I had my two
directors down there Jeff Wilson and
Alastair Fothergill and then some of the
greatest nature photographers in the
world they're just amazing so was this
all in place when you were brought on
board or yeah we partner with a
wonderful company a silverback
productions and Alastair and Jeff both
worked on Frozen Planet they were in
love with these little creatures you
know we like to say that the Adelie is
half the size of an emperor with twice
the personality and they they just
adored this story and they knew they
wanted to tell you know we the trope in
these often times is the mother cub
mother chick and in this particular case
we could tell a father story and it was
something that really got them excited
and now was this an open casting call
how did you find Steve Steve you know
many people ask about Steve his agent is
amazing
Steve actually was one penguin and he
had a lot of stunt doubles the the
penguin in the nest you know the fact
that they are always in the same nest we
were able to follow that one penguin who
just had so much personality Jeff Wilson
that was in Cape Crozier which is near
McMurdo Station it is the windiest place
on earth and interestingly one of the
driest places on earth
hmm and so he found Steve and fell in
love with him because he was such a you
know specific little personality and
each you know the interesting thing
about these animals is they all have a
personality and so you you know some of
them you
approach many of them will approach you
but some will you know fight back some
will run away some will come up and just
kind of sit you know sit down with you
and Steve hit you up for money or all
the time all the time but because I
wondered if that didn't have to happen
because there were junctures which were
clearly dramatic moments you think is
Steve gonna make it yeah well you know
essentially survival is what this story
is about survival and being a good dad I
think is the two things you know
definitely how we craft these stories is
essentially our cinematographers are out
in the field and they're really you know
journaling all the behavior so the
behavior that you're seeing is all
behavior that that we're capturing and
then you know unlike my day job
is in animation where we start
everything from whole cloth in this
particular sense we get images with lots
of kind of you know these guys out in
the field or you know behavioral
scientists biologists you know they
they're just phenomenal and then we're
able to then thread that story using the
images that they bring because in
physics there's the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle that the observer
changes the thing observed that must be
the concern in documentary films - well
definitely in this case you know it's
it's interesting because if you're
shooting big cats like in you know the
snow leopards and born in China or the
on the Serengeti when you're doing lions
and whatnot you don't get close to them
but they're aware that you're there
there are certain animals like the
penguin like monkeys who if you're there
they will interact with you so one of
the things you know for instance on we
were in five different locations on that
arctica Cape Crozier we actually hiked
about 40 minutes away from the camp from
from the nesting area because we didn't
want them to get used to us and better
as you see even I love these films at
the end when you get to see a little bit
of the making of
they will they will come up with you
regardless we were really careful
everything that you see in the nesting
area was done with long you know with
photo law you know telephoto lenses
because if you get in there and distract
the Penguins the skewers are a big
threat and so you you know we stayed
away from that but anything outside that
range they would walk right by and you
had biologists on site who were letting
you know what was happening yeah I'm
supposed to you know my to director is
both of phd's and behavior don't we all
because this is such a is pitch to such
a young audience too and it's not like a
nature documentary of the old days where
the the narrator hid in the bushes what
you're seeing now among the blue
throated creep the Marlon Perkins
approach this is the mind the Marlon
Perkins approach um but the voice of
Steve the narration the character of
Steve was also that tone it wasn't like
I'm going off to breed now I'm going off
to start a family so the language was
very g-rated was it was constructed
everything with with that kind of young
audience in mind well it's interesting
because this particular piece I don't
you know the this is my third
Disneynature film and it is definitely
the one that we felt we could actually
invest most in the comedy and in the
character and actually we try and stay
away from actually having characters
speak in these things but it was such
kind of an it just felt right to do that
and they're so damn adorable just
amazing and you can see their thought
process which is another thing that just
is phenomenal with him so you know on
this particular one we were you know we
looked at Steve is kind of the every
penguin and so we were very lucky to get
ed Helmes who we think of as kind of the
everyman and my director Jeff Wilson was
he's a millennial dad hence the
soundscape that rather the the musical
pieces in there is it's Jeff it's it's
what his three year old his five year
old and his seven year old here in the
back of the van when they he's taking
them places so yeah it's it you know we
really felt on this when we could kind
of go out on a limb a little bit and
push it a little further and having ed
Helmes also change or shape the
character absolutely I mean I think ed
Helmes when he came for that the great
thing about Edie and you know I've done
a lot of voiceover in the 26 years that
I've been with Disney he came in so
prepared with so many questions and he
was so in love with this character and
you know obviously we recorded the
script and we went through the the the
entire film and then we would go back to
sections and just let him riff certainly
all this stuff when he's running up onto
the shore and falling over and whatnot
it's all timed to him just watching the
film and going he's he's just a
delightful delightful human being or
economy thanks for being so generous
with your time here it is my pleasure it
is absolutely sure